welcome back to me rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is going to be my initial
reaction to the trailer regarding to the
Galaxy Vol 3. after we got the Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special on Disney
plus last week I am so so excited for
this movie coming in May 2023 I'm gonna
give my initial Impressions and
reactions to all the highlights that we
see in this trailer in this video and
then tomorrow will be my frame by frame
breakdown of all the hidden details and
Easter eggs and references all the stuff
that's kind of hard to catch but let's
react to this here we go well it's just
into the tape deck the awesome mix
we were gone for quite a while all right
they're on the Bowie this is the new
ship that they have and remember what
happens next
oh just landed in this you still needs
new uniforms oh we come in peace
okay that's not earth never mind
oh no
seriously dude
oh no
what is going on
oh this is in the meantime by spacehog
okay
wow
where are we
that's in nowhere
what happened to Peter Pete I'm done
running
oh wow this all looks incredible all
right there we go I evolutionary 2001
Space Odyssey reference there
oh well they're waiting
what
oh this is gonna hurt
it's his girlfriend Adam Warlock has
arrived
oh man small group oh he's got all the
different arms
oh it translated it's uh either
zandarian or the scroll language
and they'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
oh my God I am here for this movie okay
so the song that we hear in this trailer
is in the meantime by spacehog came out
in 1995 and uh here's a quote about the
song from lead singer Royston Langdon he
says it's me trying to reach people it's
using some kind of metaphor or a worldly
or in a worldly search for the end of
isolation and the acceptance of oneself
is in there at the end of the day it's
saying whatever you got to do it's okay
it's all right and I think it's also me
talking to myself getting through my Wan
anxieties and fear of death it's what it
all comes down to what's so beautiful
about it is that it continues to connect
with people the lyrics of the song begin
with the words and in the end we shall
achieve in time the thing they called
Divine and one thing we learned from the
Guardians holiday special is that mantis
is a half sister to Peter Quill she's
also a child of the celestial ego so
this genetic history is going to be very
important to Guardians volume 3.
especially since the villain of the
story is going to be Herbert Wyndham the
high evolutionary played by chukwidi
Ouija he's considered Marvel's Ultimate
geneticist he's always the mad scientist
who's experimenting on creatures he
created the new men and it looks like in
this movie it's gonna be revealed that
he was the one who created Rocket
Raccoon who was not a raccoon he was
another creature who was just
genetically modified to look like a
raccoon and that dark history has been
hinted at from the very first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie rocket has always
had this existential crisis he's always
had a bit of resentment over the people
who actually created him so rocket is
going to be learning about his genetic
origin um Peter quilliamantis are going
to be learning about their true nature
because as carriers of celestial DNA
they're going to be carrying the light
they are children of gods in a way what
does that mean for them
for all the Guardians like I theorized
this week that the reason swole Groot is
so swole is that his photonic knowledge
may be coming from a photosynthesis
process in which he's absorbing the
light of celestials in his company and
another major thing revealed about
rocket here is he's going to reunite
with his old partner Lila lady Lila who
resembles an otter in the comics but
like rocket is not a raccoon Lila is not
an otter uh Lila was actually mentioned
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie on Rockets xandar booking screen
and we always wondered if she might show
up in this movie and now they're already
confirming that she is both of them
originate from half world but it seems
like both of them are going to be
creations of Herbert Wyndham now we are
all content Junkies you me I guess
everybody with internet connection 2022
all of us but there are times when a
screen isn't an option and for those
times when you've got to go Audio Only
audibles the best way to go Audible has
an incredible selection of audiobooks
across every genre from Best Sellers and
new releases to celebrity Memoirs
Mysteries and thrillers motivation
Wellness business and more and you're
not just getting books read to you dryly
they're actually being performed for you
by Major stars like Ethan Hawke
Washington Kevin Hart as an audible
member you can choose one title a month
to keep from their entire catalog
including the latest bestsellers and new
releases members also get full access to
a growing selection of included
audiobooks audible originals and
podcasts you can download or stream
included titles all you want the
constant influx of new titles gives an
audible membership such crazy bang for
your buck and if you're a new member you
can try audible free for 30 days that's
how I got hooked I was listening to Andy
Circus Gollum himself read the Lord of
the Rings trilogy
oh I'm sorry I've been talking over you
okay
let audible help you discover new ways
to laugh and be inspired or be
entertained new members can try audible
free for 30 days visit audible.com new
rockstars or text new rockstars to 500
500. we also meet Will Poulter as Adam
Warlock he's even got the little spot on
his forehead where normally in the
comics an infinity stone would go this
in his forehead is probably not an
infinity stone but it's some kind of
bolt that visually ties in with the fact
that he carried the Soul Stone in his
head Adam Warlock is played by Will
Poulter who got super jacked for this
role though not a swallow swole group he
originated in Aisha the sovereign's
cocoon that was sent in the post-credits
scene at guardians galaxy Vol 2. so
let's talk about this planet that the
Guardians of the Galaxy visit in their
new ship which by the way is again
called the Bowie a reference to David
Bowie David Bowie's moonage Daydream is
the music that was playing with the
guardian's first visited xandar in the
2014 film but this planet at first looks
like Earth we even see what looks like a
Statue of Liberty but I think in kind of
a Planet of the Apes sort of thing
that's going to be revealed as some
other kind of a woodland creature I
think we are seeing half World here or
at least the MCU version of half World
which seems like version of Earth and
Earth suburbs is actually populated by
Society of bipedal Woodland creatures
which I think are going to be creations
of Herbert Wyndham I think we are
looking at the at the men or whatever
the MCU will call
you they're all kind of like rocket a
mixture of things that vaguely look like
Terran mammals walk around wearing human
clothes specifically they're all wearing
like 80s apparel so they're not just in
this alternate reality of this alternate
world they're specifically a world set
in the 1980s so what are we looking at
here have they ventured into the
Multiverse are we looking at another
reality where Herbert Windham lives I
think that's more likely than just
another planet that just happens to
match the cityscape the architecture the
fashion the social norms and if this is
grounded the Multiverse that suggests
that Herbert window might have an
association with Kang or other people
can hop across different universes I'm
going to explore this a lot more in the
breakdown that's going to come out
tomorrow don't worry it looks like James
Gunn worked in a reference to the game
Among Us based off of the spacesuits
that they're wearing each one a
different color whatever they are
leaping down onto it looks like flesh
like this some kind of creature that
they're exploring here and at a minute
and one second into the trailer this
creature has at the base of it some
portal of light I'm just reaching here
but I wonder if this could be some kind
of part of the rest of the body of
nowhere we know the Guardians have now
set up shop in nowhere that's kind of
their home base but we don't know where
the rest of nowhere's body is and we
believe that celestials are beans made
out of some kind of plasmic light I made
looking at nowhere spinal cord that's
all just kind of coiled up right now and
if you go into it you can access the
light that maybe leads you to a portal
to another dimension we don't really
know the power hierarchy of celestials
are in the MCU but it wouldn't surprise
me if they could be kind of universe
independent it could kind of hop through
universes and oversee it all I really
don't know where my brain just went
there but I hope you enjoyed it and of
course Gamora is going to return to the
story and the Comic-Con trailer is
revealed that she's now gonna be leading
a certain subgroup of ravagers but again
this is the Gamora from the 2014 era of
the timeline who traveled back with
Thanos to the present and Avengers end
game she doesn't have all the same
memories that Gamora did when she died
in Avengers Infinity War okay there's so
much more to dig into from this trailer
I can't wait to go through it green by
frame again that will be tomorrow's
Easter egg breakdown video there's
obviously so much to talk about I can't
wait to go through it frame by frame but
hey if you want to see us live and you
happen to be in the LA area this weekend
come to Los Angeles Comic Con downtown
L.A because new rock stars will be
hosting a panel on Sunday December 4th
at 10 30 a.m we're going to be talking
about this trailer you can come tell me
your theories in person I can't wait to
meet you all be sure to subscribe to new
rock stars at new rockstars follow me at
EA boss thank you so much for watching
see you next time bye
[Music]